WT-FDA.
(APPLAUSE)
AMPLIFYING GLASS.COM
FEATURES FOREIGN FOOD LABELS
THAT HAVE BEEN TRANSLATED
INTO ENGLISH FOR EXPORT AND IT
MADE THEM A LOT LESS
APPETIZING, SO I WILL SHOW
YOU SOME OF THESE FOODS AND
YOU GIVE ME A TAGLINE TO SELL
THE PRODUCT, ALL RIGHT.
FIRST ONE, THIS CHILD
SHREDDED MEAT.
>> CHILD SHREDDED MEAT,
BRENDON.
>> JUST LIKE ADULT SHREDDED
MEAT BUT MORE TENDER AND
WITH LESS PUBES.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> POINTS.
>> JESSE.
>> LOOK FOR IT IN YOUR LOCAL
SEX OFFENDER'S FREEZER.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> DEON.
>> I TOLD YOU TO SHUT THE
HELL UP, BILLY.
(LAUGHTER)
POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, HOW
ABOUT A STEAMY BOWL OF SOUP
FOR SLUTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT HAS ALL THE VITAMINS
AND MINERALS THAT HEALTHY
SLUTS NEED.
JESSE.
>> HOMEMADE SOUP JUST LIKE
YOUR MOM AND WHOEVER SHE WAS
[BLEEP] USED TO MAKE.
>> POINTS.
>> DEON.
>> TWO GIRLS, ONE CUP
-- OF DELICIOUS SOUP.
(APPLAUSE)
>> BRENDON.
>> COME GUZZLE SOMETHING
ELSE FOR A CHANGE.
(APPLAUSE)
>> YOU DID START THAT OFF
WITH COME.
>> COME-- LIKE JOIN ME.
>> JOIN ME.
>> NEXT ONE, A HOT CUP OF
URINAL!
>> WOULDN'T IT BE FUNNY IF
YOU OPENED IT UP AND IT WAS
A LITTLE BLUE DISK, JESSE?
>> NOW A PROUD SPONSOR FOR
THE R. KELLY FOUNDATION FOR
RUNNAWAY TEENS.
>> POINTS.
>> ANYONE ELSE.
>> BRENDON.
>> THE PERFECT DRINK FOR
TAKING A WIZ AND CHECKING
OUT OTHER DUDE'S DICKS.
>> YOU NEED A DRINK FOR
THAT?
>> NICE TO HAVE A MUG WHILE
YOU'RE--
(LAUGHTER)
>> IF YOU GO INTO A BATHROOM
AND SOME GUY IS SIPPING TEA,
JUST LEAVE THAT BATHROOM.
>> NEXT ONE A FROZEN GOLDEN
GAY TIME.
>> YEAH, JESSE.
>> GOLDEN GAY TIME, WHAT
TIME IS IT, IT'S TIME FOR
JOHN TRAVOLTA'S DEEP TISSUE
MASSAGE.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> NO POINTS.
>> OH.
>> DEON.
>> GET A LOAD OF THIS.
>> ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
>> LAST ONE, HOW ABOUT THIS
ANTI-SEMITIC BEVERAGE.
>> FOR THOSE YOU WHO CAN'T
SEE IN THE BACK IT SAYS THE
JEW'S EAR JUICE.
ALL RIGHT, THAT IS WHAT IT
SAYS THERE.
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP] COULD
THAT POSSIBLY BE?
WHAT COULD THAT POSSIBLY BE?
>> IT IS AS IT RIGHT ON THE
CAN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT'S JEW'S EAR JUICE.
>> YOU WENT TO THE FACTORY
LIKE, WHAT IS THIS REALLY, NO,
IT'S LITERAL, JUST BE
LIKE A BUNCH OF EARLESS JEWS.
JESSE JOYCE.
>> HEALTHY PART OF A
BALANCED BUDGET.
(APPLAUSE)
>> ADOREABLE, POINTS.
>> GOOD ONE.
>> BRENDAN.
>> BROUGHT TO YOU FROM THE
MAKERS OF THE GAZA BREATH
STRIPS.